So Viola disguises herself as a man, takes a job working for this guy, who she promptly falls in love with. He believes the pretense, thinks Viola's a man. And so he has no interest in her. And at some point, her boss notices that Viola does seem to have a crush on someone and asks her about it.
薇奥拉把自己伪装成男人，给这个人打工，并很快爱上了他。他相信了她的伪装，认为薇奥拉是个男人，所以对她毫无兴趣。后来，她的老板注意到薇奥拉似乎暗恋着某人，便问起了这件事。
Here's what happens. This is actually the Shakespeare play Twelfth Night, second act. Viola's boss, the Duke Orsino, asks if her eye has fallen on someone she loves. Viola replies, "A little, by your favor." The duke asks, "What kind of woman is it?"
事情是这样的。这实际上是莎士比亚戏剧《第十二夜》第二幕的情节。薇奥拉的老板，奥西诺公爵，问她的心是否落在了某个她所爱的人身上。薇奥拉回答：“略有一点，承蒙大人关照。”公爵问：“那是什么样的女人？”
Viola is, of course, in a difficult position because it's him that she loves. What kind of woman is it? She replies, "Of your complexion." "She is not worth thee, then," he says. "What years, in faith?" "About your years, my lord."
薇奥拉当然处于一个尴尬的境地，因为她爱的人正是他。那是什么样的女人？她回答：“跟您的容貌差不多。”他说：“那她就不值得你了。那么，年纪呢，老实说？”“大概跟您的年纪相仿，大人。”
Then they go on to talk about the woman that the duke is in love with, who is named Olivia, who doesn't like the duke at all. And Viola tentatively brings up the notion, "What if there were some lady, as perhaps there is, hath for your love a great a pang of heart as you have for Olivia?" He replies that no woman could feel for him as deeply as he feels for Olivia.
接着他们开始谈论公爵所爱的那个女人，名叫奥利维亚，而奥利维亚根本不喜欢公爵。薇奥拉试探性地提出了一个想法：“如果有一位女士，也许确实有，她对您的爱就像您对奥利维亚的一样深沉，那会怎样？”他回答说，没有女人能像他爱奥利维亚那样深沉地爱他。
And Viola has another one of these sad little moments, where she feels this compulsion to hint at her feelings for the duke without him understanding at all what she is driving at, because he thinks that she's a man. She says, "A woman can love as deeply as a man does. My father had a daughter loved a man as it might be, perhaps, were I woman, I should your lordship."
薇奥拉又经历了一次这种悲伤的小时刻，她感到一种冲动，想要暗示她对公爵的感情，但他却完全听不出她在说什么，因为他以为她是个男人。她说：“女人也能像男人一样深沉地爱。我父亲有个女儿，爱上了一个男人，就像……如果我是个女人，我也许会爱上大人您一样。”
So the duke asks about this daughter of her father's. What's her history? "A blank, my lord. She never told her love, but let concealment, like a worm in the bud, feed on her damask cheek. She pined in thought, and with a green and yellow melancholy, she sat like Patience on a monument, smiling at grief."
于是公爵问起她父亲的那个女儿。她的故事是什么？“这是一片空白，大人。她从未说出她的爱，而是让隐藏的秘密像花蕾中的蛀虫，啃食她那如锦缎般的面颊。她在忧郁中消瘦，带着一种青黄色，坐在那儿就像墓碑上的‘耐心’，微笑着面对痛苦。”
This is where things come to. She loves him. But she's pretending to be someone she's not, so her lie is like this membrane, separating her from him. Even though he's standing right there, she cannot tell him how she feels.
事情就是这样。她爱他。但她伪装成别人，所以她的谎言就像一层薄膜，将她与他隔开。即使他就站在那里，她也无法告诉他她的感受。
The problem with pretending is that you can just be too successful. And someone will believe you. And then you're stuck.
伪装的问题在于，你可能会演得太成功。别人会信以为真。然后你就被困住了。
And of course, there's a second and a deeper danger that Shakespeare doesn't talk about in Twelfth Night. The real trouble that you can get into if you pretend that you're someone else is not that other people are going to believe it. It's that you'll start to believe it yourself. And then you're just living in a dream.
当然，还有第二个更深层的危险，莎士比亚在《第十二夜》中没有提到。当你伪装成别人时，真正陷入的麻烦并不是别人会相信它。而是你自己也会开始相信它。然后你就生活在梦境里了。
You see so many public figures-- senators, for example-- who are so enamored with the fact that they are, in fact, senators of the United States of America. They turn into these cartoon people. You look at them, and you just get the feeling that they never stop saying to themselves, "I am the senator." They go mad.
你见过许多公众人物——比如参议员——他们是如此沉迷于自己是美国参议员这一事实。他们变成了那种卡通人物。你看着他们，只会觉得他们从未停止对自己说：“我就是参议员。”他们疯了。
And this happens in all sorts of ways, large and small, people pretending all sorts of things. That they feel things they don't really feel, that they are things that they, in fact, are not. The craziest people are the ones who come to believe their own lies, in their families, at their jobs.
这种情况以各种形式发生，大大小小，人们伪装各种事情。他们表现出自己并非真实感受的情感，表现出自己并非真实身份的状态。最疯狂的人是那些在家庭、工作中开始相信自己谎言的人。
Well, from WBEZ Chicago and Public Radio International, it's This American Life. I'm Ira Glass. Each week on our program, we choose a theme, bring you a variety of different kinds of stories on that theme. Today's program, Be Careful Who You Pretend to Be. We have three cautionary tales for you.
这里是芝加哥WBEZ电台和国际公共广播电台联合制作的《这一美国生活》。我是艾拉·格拉斯。每周节目中，我们都会选择一个主题，为您带来关于该主题的各种故事。今天的节目是：“小心你所伪装的人”。我们为您准备了三个警示故事。
Act One, Doing Good by Doing Bad, what happens when a nice guy gets a job where all day long, he is supposed to pretend that he's a son of a bitch. How does it affect him? Act Two, Psychobabble, Qu'est-ce Que C'est. Jack Hitt tells a true story of those innocent days back in the '70s when going to a church retreat meant back rubs and encounter group sessions and role-playing games, and how he personally witnessed the role-playing game to end all role-playing games. Act Three, What's So Funny About Peace, Love, and Understanding? Reporter Alix Spiegel heads out with a group of mostly white suburbanites who are on a mission to understand the African-American slave experience by pretending to be African-American slaves. Stay with us.
第一幕，“以恶行善”，当一个好人得到了一份需要整天伪装成混蛋的工作时，会发生什么？这对他有什么影响？第二幕，“心理呓语，那是什么”。杰克·希特讲述了一个真实的70年代故事，那时参加教会退修会意味着背部按摩、遭遇小组会议和角色扮演游戏，以及他如何亲眼目睹了那场终极的角色扮演游戏。第三幕，“和平、爱与理解有什么可笑的？”记者艾丽克斯·斯皮格尔与一群大多是白人郊区居民一同出发，他们的使命是通过伪装成非裔美国奴隶来了解非裔美国奴隶的经历。请继续收听。
Act One, Doing Good by Doing Bad. What happens when you're pretending to be somebody horrible every day? How does it change you?
第一幕，“以恶行善”。当你每天都伪装成一个可怕的人时，会发生什么？它如何改变了你？
Ron Copeland worked for a union for 27 years, left that work. And then he saw an ad in the paper calling for people who like children, who like to teach history in an innovative way. And this led him to a job as a historical interpreter at the Conner Prairie Living History Museum, outside of Indianapolis.
罗恩·科普兰为工会工作了27年，离开了那份工作。后来他在报纸上看到一则广告，招募喜欢孩子、喜欢以创新方式教授历史的人。这让他得到了一份位于印第安纳波利斯郊外康纳草原生活历史博物馆的历史讲解员的工作。
For several months a year, in his job, he pretends to be a slaveowner in the old South. People come looking to experience the slave experience. He screams at them. He orders them around. He treats them terribly. He talked about his job with This American Life producer Alix Spiegel.
他每年有几个月的时间，工作就是伪装成旧南方的奴隶主。人们来这里是为了体验奴隶的经历。他会对他们尖叫。他会命令他们。他会残酷地对待他们。他与《这一美国生活》的制片人艾丽克斯·斯皮格尔谈论了他的工作。
It was very hard. At first we couldn't really scream at them. It was not in our makeup to actually talk to the people in rough tones and voices. You had to develop over a period of time. It took us some time to start the yelling. It took us some time to get actually mean, and especially when you start talking to black people in that tone.
那非常艰难。起初我们真的无法对他们大吼大叫。用粗鲁的语调和嗓音去和人们交谈并不是我们的本性。你必须在一段时间内慢慢培养。我们花了一些时间才开始吼叫。我们花了一些时间才真正变得刻薄，尤其是当你用那种语调和黑人说话时。
So the very first time, it was not very loud at all. I may have said "Get down here. You cattle, get down here. Get down here right now. Get on your hands and knees. Get down here in front of me."
所以第一次尝试时，声音一点也不响。我可能只是说：“到这儿来。你们这些牲口，到这儿来。现在立刻到这儿来。跪下，跪在手和膝盖上。跪到我面前。”
Then the second time around, it was, "You slaves, get down here. Get down on your hands and knees. Start getting down here. Put your eyes down. Don't you be looking up at a white man. You know you're not supposed to be looking up at me. Get your eyes down on the ground. Get down here."
第二次时，就变成了：“你们这些奴隶，到这儿来。跪在手和膝盖上。开始跪下。把眼睛低下去。别抬头看白人。你知道你不应该抬头看我。把眼睛看地。到这儿来。”
The harshest is, "Get down here today! Get down here right now! Don't you be looking up at me! Get down here right now!
最刻薄的是：“今天就到这儿来！现在立刻到这儿来！别抬头看我！现在立刻到这儿来！”
You bucks, get over here. Let me see you. Don't look up at me. Are you looking up at me?"
“你们这些壮丁，过来。让我看着你们。别抬头看我。你们在抬头看我吗？”
And what you want to do is you want to get their attention very quickly. Then you start working upon their emotions. You look for that little weakness in a person. If you find a weakness, then you start playing on that weakness.
你想做的是尽快吸引他们的注意。然后你开始操纵他们的情绪。寻找一个人的弱点。如果你找到了弱点，就开始利用它。
If you see a lady start batting her eyes and start flinching a little bit, you work on her. Tell her, you're going to keep her for yourself. She's going to be away from the rest of the group. They're going to go on without her. She belongs to you. You put fear in her.
如果你看到一位女士开始眨眼、身体微微颤抖，你就对她下手。告诉她，你会把她留给自己。她会与其他人分开。他们会抛下她继续前进。她属于你。你在她心中植入恐惧。
Now it may sound funny to you, but it's like the military. The first thing they do in the military is they break you down. And then they put you back as a unit. And that's what you're trying to do with these folks.
现在这听起来可能很好笑，但就像军队一样。军队做的第一件事就是击垮你的意志，然后把你重塑成一个整体单位。这正是你对这些人想做的事情。
I even went so far last night to get a big order of onion rings so that you got that onion breath to get right in their face. Because you want them to really feel you, to sense you. It's in the dark. If you get right up in their face, and you got that tobacco smell and onion breath and all this, garlic breath, they're wanting to back away from you. And the more they back, the closer you get to them.
昨晚我甚至还去买了满满一份洋葱圈，这样就能有那种洋葱口气，直接喷在他们脸上。因为你想让他们真正感受到你。是在黑暗中。如果你直接凑到他们脸上，身上有那种烟草味、洋葱味、大蒜味，他们会想要躲开。而他们后退得越多，你就越靠近他们。
I like to walk around behind them and talk to them. But they don't know which one you're talking to. And you say, well, that one right there, I think she'd be good for breeding, because look at those hips on her.
我喜欢在他们背后走来走去和他们说话。但他们不知道你在和谁说话。然后你说，嗯，就是那个，我想她适合繁育，看看她的臀部。
And you're standing behind three women. They're all standing there thinking, "Is he talking about me? Is he making that remark about me?"
你站在三个女人身后。她们都站在那里想：“他在说我吗？他在评论我吗？”
You're not making it about any one of them. You're just saying it. But they don't know that.
你并不是针对她们中的任何一个。你只是随口一说。但她们不知道。
Or you get up behind them. They can feel you're behind them. They know you're back there. You can sense a person's back there.
或者你站到她们身后。她们能感觉到你在后面。她们知道你在那儿。你能感觉到有人在身后。
But you don't say a word. It puts them on an edge. Anything you can do to scare them, to agitate them, to isolate them, you push.
但你一言不发。这让她们处于紧张状态。任何能吓唬她们、扰乱她们、孤立她们的事情，你都去做。
There was many a nights, when we first started the program, that I would go home and lay awake all night, because it's emotionally, in your head, this is wrong. You're doing something that's very wrong. Even though you're trying to show history to them and make it realistic for them, it's still very hard, because it's not our nature to act like that. You see somebody tear up.
刚开始这个项目时，有很多个晚上我回家躺着整夜睡不着觉，因为从情感上讲，在你的脑海里，这是不对的。你在做一件非常错误的事。尽管你在努力向他们展示历史，让他们感到真实，但依然很难，因为这种行为不是我们的本性。你看到有人流泪。
Well, I'm kind of a softie, anyway. And it hurt me. I'm thinking, "I'm too rough on her." If it's an older person, you're thinking, "Am I going to make that person have a heart attack?"
嗯，我本来就是个心软的人。这让我很痛苦。我在想：“我对她太粗暴了。”如果是老年人，你会想：“我会不会把那个人吓出心脏病来？”
Now Monday, I done a program out here. And I had a young girl. And I told her she was going to do this. And I screamed at her and made her get over in the corner. And she started crying and started bawling. And it's very hard then.
周一我做了一个节目。有一个小女孩。我告诉她她要这样做。我对着她尖叫，让她去角落。她开始哭泣，开始嚎叫。那之后真的很难受。
And I had to come out of it to a point of where I said, "Well you's too skinny. I don't think you can cook. You wouldn't be very good at all having children," and all this, and then told her to get out of there. But you felt real bad.
我不得不跳出那个角色，说道：“嗯，你太瘦了。我觉得你做不好饭。你生不了孩子，”等等，然后让她走开。但你感觉真的很糟糕。
As soon as she walked out, my first instinct was you wanted to go find out she was all right. Because I know she's going to carry that home with her. So it hurts. It hurts.
她一走出去，我的第一本能就是想去看看她是否还好。因为我知道她会把这种阴影带回家。所以这很痛苦。真的很痛苦。
Do you treat the blacks differently than you treat the whites?
你对待黑人和白人的方式不同吗？
We try not to. We try not to. What we try to do is we'll pick on a black one, and then we'll pick on a white one. And we try to give them equal treatment at the same time, so that we are not judging them.
我们尽量不去区别对待。我们尽量挑一个黑人，然后再挑一个白人。我们尽量同时给予他们平等的待遇，这样我们就不会产生偏见。
But do you find yourself treating them differently anyway?
但你发现自己还是不自觉地区别对待了吗？
I would say, yes. You do. You do. You can't help from it. You can't help from treating them just a little bit better than you would the white person. Because with problems that we've had in the past, with the relations and the way that people have been treated at all, you don't know how you're going to push that person's trigger.
我会说，是的。会有的。你忍不住。你忍不住会比对待白人稍微好那么一点点。因为过去我们遇到过种种问题，人际关系和人们过去遭受的对待方式，你不知道什么时候会触发那个人的心结。
So have you ever really just let loose?
那么，你有过真正放开自我的时候吗？
Oh, yes. On a black person, I've let loose. I've let loose and really called them stupid, ignorant. "You're nothing but an animal. You're just like a child. I've got to teach you everything. You're just like a little animal. You don't know a damn thing. What are you, stupid?" And just keep in their face constantly, talking to them on it and yelling at them.
哦，有的。对黑人，我有过放开的时候。我彻底放开，真的叫他们愚蠢、无知。“你们不过是动物。你们就像孩子。我得教你们一切。你们就像小动物。你们什么都不懂。你们怎么了，蠢货吗？”一直对着他们吼叫。
And what are you thinking about yourself inside, when you're doing that?
当你这样做的时候，你在心里是怎么想自己的？
Inside, your stomach is turning. It's constantly turning. You can feel it knotting up inside. There's that little feeling in the back of your head, "You're not like this."
内心深处，你的胃在翻江倒海。一直在翻腾。你能感觉到里面在打结。你的脑后有一个小小的声音在说：“你不是这样的人。”
Now have you ever had a moment in doing this where you were sitting there, yelling at somebody, and you were like, "I can imagine myself," or I can see how you could be this person?
在做这件事的时候，有没有某个瞬间，你坐在那儿对着某人吼叫，你会觉得：“我能想象自己，”或者我能看出你如何能成为这样的人？
Oh, certainly. I've had a moment like that, that I could be that. I've had them where I could see that I could have been that mean a person, if someone was being that stupid and that dumb and that defiant of me.
哦，当然。我有过那样的时刻，我能看出我能成为那样的人，如果有人那么愚蠢、那么迟钝、那么公然违抗我的话。
I had a black lady. Now normally, that's been with whites. But I had a black lady, and she was very defiant.
有一位黑人女士。通常这种情况是针对白人的。但我遇到过一位黑人女士，她非常反抗。
The look on her face, the look out of her eyes was a burning look. I'm out there in the dark, and I could see them eyes piercing me. And I tried to make her do some of the things, and it was like she was going to defy me no matter whatever I done.
她脸上的表情，她眼神里的东西，是一种灼热的目光。我站在黑暗中，能看到那双眼睛刺向我。我试图强迫她做一些事情，但她似乎无论我做什么都要反抗到底。
And no matter how close I got to her, I got within an inch of her nose from my nose. And I was screaming at her. And I told her to look down. And she would not bat her eye. She would not even talk.
无论我离她有多近，我离她的鼻子只有一英寸。我对着她尖叫。我让她往下看。她连眼睛都不眨一下。她甚至一句话都不说。
And finally I come to the point. And I said, "Ma'am. Tell you what's going to happen to you. I'm just going to kill you right here. Now do you care about that?" And she looked at me with those eyes. And they were very piercing.
最后我忍无可忍。我说：“女士。告诉你将会发生什么。我就在这里杀了你。你现在在乎了吗？”她用那双眼睛看着我。那目光非常锐利。
And she says, "I guess you're just going to have to kill me because I'm not doing anything. Go ahead and kill me. I'm not going to do it." And those eyes were burning into me.
她说：“我想你只能杀了我，因为我什么都不会做。来吧，杀了我。我不做。”那双眼睛深深地刺进我的心里。
And I'm thinking, if I was a slave buyer, I would have probably pulled the gun up and shot her right between the eyes. Because she had pushed my trigger then. I'm thinking, that's not right. That's not right. But for that moment, I would have probably pulled the gun out and killed her, right then.
我在想，如果我真的是个奴隶买主，我可能已经拔出枪，对着她的双眼之间开火了。因为她触碰了我的底线。我在想，这不对。这不对。但在那一刻，我可能真的会拔出枪杀了她。
We've had some come through, saying that they feel like we're going beyond acting, that we actually get a kick out of being sadistic, like we are, which we don't. We don't. I can tell you that even one of the interpreters up there, it was his first time. And he got into it so much that after the program was over, he was actually physically sick. Because it affects you that way.
曾有人走过来，说他们觉得我们不仅仅是在演戏，我们实际上是在享受这种施虐的过程，其实不然。我们没有。我可以告诉你，即使是一个在那里工作的讲解员，那是他第一次。他投入得太深，以至于节目结束后，他真的生理上感到恶心。因为这种事会那样影响你。
He was physically sick meaning he threw up?
生理上感到恶心，意思是说他呕吐了吗？
He threw up out there afterwards.
他事后在那边吐了。
When you take off your costume, and you put on your civilian clothes to go outside and go home, you feel like 50 pounds has been off each shoulder. All you want to do is get out of here and get back to your life at your home, today, in 1998. You don't want to think about that there. But you catch yourself driving home thinking about it. That was really vicious. That was really tough.
当你脱下戏服，穿上平民服装回家时，你感觉肩膀上卸下了50磅重担。你只想离开这里，回到你今天，在1998年的生活中。你不想再想那里的事。但你在开车回家的路上还是会忍不住想起它。那真的很恶毒。那真的太残酷了。
And then when you get home, you try to get it out of your head. I go and I sit in the living room. I get me a Coke. I sit there with no television on. And I replay the entire night and go over it.
然后当你回到家，你试着把它从脑子里赶走。我坐进起居室。拿了一瓶可乐。我不开电视就坐在那儿。我反复重演整晚的过程。
Did I do this right? Did I do that right? Was I too mean to this person? Should I have done this? So I sort of replay the whole thing.
我做得对吗？我那样做对吗？我对那个人太刻薄了吗？我本该那样做吗？我就像是在复盘整个过程。
And then I try to justify what I've done with myself. I wasn't mean. I didn't treat that person too bad. I was backing off just a little bit. And I wasn't any worse tonight than I was last night. So I have not hurt anybody. I have not done anything. So you sort of just sit there and talk yourself. It's a mental thing.
然后我试着为自己所做的辩解。我并不刻薄。我对待那个人并没有太糟糕。我其实已经收敛了。我今晚并不比昨晚更过分。所以我没有伤害任何人。我什么都没做。所以你就像那样坐在那儿说服自己。这是一种心理作用。
Do you ever feel now in going about the daily business of your life that you could get set off?
你在处理日常生活时，有没有感到自己会被触发的时刻？
I scream a lot. I do, little things. My wife says that I tend to talk a lot louder. It's more of I'm trying to tell people, not ask people. She said I've changed in that manner, to where it's not like I used to be.
我吼叫得很多。真的，一点小事也会。我妻子说我说话的声音倾向于大得多。我更是在尝试命令人们，而不是请求人们。她说我在那方面改变了，不像以前那样了。
I was laid back. I talked to people in a soft tone. But now, she says, you're more demanding. You're more forceful in the way you do things. And it carries over. I'm sure it does a little bit. But we try to get rid of it.
我以前很放松。我说话温和。但现在，她说，你更苛刻了。你在做事时更强硬了。这会有所延续。我相信确实有一点。但我们试图摆脱它。
Did you ever think that you could be this much of a sadist?
你有没有想过自己竟然能成为一个施虐者？
No, never, never, ever could. My wife said there was no way, because I've always been the clown, the one that laughed, cut-up, good-natured. And I didn't truly, deeply think I could, either.
没有，从没想过。我妻子说绝不可能，因为我一直是个开心果，那个爱笑、爱闹、好脾气的人。我真的一点也没想到我能做到。
It has taken a period of time to build up. We started in March. We're in November now. And I'm just now getting down to it. The screaming part I could do. But the actual getting mean, getting in the face, getting the scare, I didn't think I'd ever be able to do it.
这花了一段时间积累。我们从三月开始。现在是十一月。我才刚刚摸到门道。吼叫的部分我能做到。但真正变得刻薄、直面他人、制造恐惧，我从没想到我能做到。
So does that tell you something about yourself?
那么这是否说明了你性格中的某些东西？
Well, I'm sure each one of us has got a mean streak inside of them. And it has just got to be drawn out of them. Certainly, you question yourself and what you are, and what you thought you were. So you question yourself.
嗯，我相信每个人内心深处都有刻薄的一面。它只是需要被引出来。当然，你会质疑自己，质疑你是什么样的人，质疑你以为自己是什么样的人。所以你会自我怀疑。
How could I be this mean? Did I always have this in me? Was I actually this way, and it's never came out before? Could I continue to be mean?
我怎么能这么刻薄？我一直都有这一面吗？我其实一直都是这样，只是以前没显露出来？我能继续这么刻薄下去吗？
And you think about that a lot. It's good we're only doing this program, I think, for a month, and give us time to get away from it and forget it and not do it again. Now if we had to do this on a regular basis, constantly, it might change some of us. We might just become what we're acting out right now.
你经常会想这些。我想幸好我们只做这个节目一个月，给我们时间远离它、忘记它，不再做它。如果我们要一直常规性地做这个，可能会改变我们中的一些人。我们可能真的会变成我们现在所扮演的那种人。
You think that's a real danger, that you would become--
你觉得那是一个真正的危险，你会变成——
Oh, I think you could. I think you could. I really do. Because after being putting up with it so long, it just comes out of you. We've all got that dark spot in there, inside of us, down in there deep.
哦，我觉得有可能。我觉得有可能。我真的这么觉得。因为长时间沉浸在其中，它就会从你身上表现出来。我们所有人内心深处都有那一点黑暗的东西。
Historical interpreter Ron Copeland.
历史讲解员罗恩·科普兰。
[MUSIC PLAYING - "THE BOY DONE WRONG AGAIN" BY BELLE AND SEBASTIAN]
[音乐播放 - 贝尔与塞巴斯蒂安的《那个男孩又做错了》]
Act Two, Psychobabble, Qu'est-e Que C'est. There is the pretending we do individually, each of us, at our jobs, with our families. And then there's also a kind of industry of pretending. It includes, of course, the production of stage plays and movies, and many different kinds of sales jobs, where pretending to like your customer and your product is the key to the job. And it includes various kinds of group therapies, the role-playing games that are used in certain clinical settings.
第二幕，“心理呓语，那是什么”。我们每个人在各自工作中、与家庭相处时都有自己的伪装。此外，还有一种“伪装产业”。当然，它包括舞台剧和电影的制作，以及许多不同类型的销售工作，在这些工作中，伪装喜欢你的顾客和你的产品是成功的关键。它还包括各种群体治疗，以及在某些临床环境中使用的角色扮演游戏。
When it comes to this last category, Jack Hitt has been to the mountaintop. He has seen what there is to see. And he came back with this full report.
谈到最后一类，杰克·希特已经登峰造极。他看过了该看的一切。他带着这份完整报告回来了。
If role-playing had a heyday, it was in the '70s, and I was there. And if it had a precise peak, a moment when it reached a kind of transcendence, after which all other role-plays were but pale, wannabe role-plays, I'd argue it was the performance of Mary Frances Leopold at Camp St. Christopher on Seabrook Island, the third week of June, 1974. As it happened, I was there too.
如果角色扮演有全盛期，那就是70年代，而我在场。如果它有一个精准的巅峰，一个达到某种超越的时刻，在那之后所有其他的角色扮演都不过是苍白、拙劣的模仿，我会说那就是1974年6月的第三周，在海布鲁克岛的圣克里斯托弗营地，玛丽·弗朗西斯·利奥波德的表演。巧合的是，我也在那里。
I come to you today to testify. The backdrop, the Vietnam War, wage and price controls, the growing clamor for Nixon's resignation. I was 17. Almost everyone I knew had been expelled from school or busted for drugs. I had managed both. Extreme times called for extreme measures from our nation's clergy. And in Charleston, where I grew up, that meant only one thing, Father Ralph Byrd, youth minister.
我今天来这里作证。背景是越南战争、工资和价格管制，以及对尼克松辞职的日益强烈的呼声。我当时17岁。我认识的几乎每个人都被学校开除过，或者因为毒品被捕过。我这两样都干过。极端时期需要我们国家的神职人员采取极端措施。在查尔斯顿，我长大的地方，这意味着只有一件事：青年牧师拉尔夫·伯德神父。
Right there in Charleston, there was even a group that was on the second story of Siegling's Music House that rented rooms. And a lot of those kids left home and went up there and lived. And their parents didn't want them to be there.
就在查尔斯顿，甚至有一个租用了西格林音乐行二楼房间的群体。很多孩子离家出走住在那里。他们的父母并不希望他们在那里。
I remember that place. That was the ice cream parlor.
我还记得那个地方。那是冰淇淋店。
Yeah.
对。
Yeah, it was a brothel.
是的，那是个妓院。
Yes.
是的。
I used to hang out there. But I found out later that girls were being pressed into white slavery up there.
我过去常在那里闲逛。但后来我发现女孩们在那里被强迫从事白人奴役。
Well, some of Charleston's FOFs were up there, the Fine Old Families. They were right up there. And this was just terribly frustrating to the parents.
嗯，查尔斯顿的一些“名门望族”也在那儿。他们就在那里。这让父母感到非常沮丧。
You mean having your daughter become a prostitute? It's very frustrating, Ralph.
你是说让女儿变成妓女？这非常令人沮丧，拉尔夫。
They didn't even know that, most of the time. The ones that I dealt with, they just saw their child having left home. Later, they would discover what was really going on, which was even worse.
他们大部分时间甚至都不知道。我处理过的那些案例，他们只是看到孩子离开了家。后来他们才会发现真正发生了什么，那甚至更糟糕。
My point is we discovered that parents were sufficiently frustrated and felt utterly unempowered. And they said, "Have at it." I don't think they ever questioned us even once.
我的重点是我们发现父母们非常沮丧，感到完全无力。他们说：“随便吧。”我想他们甚至从没质疑过我们一次。
Despite the wicked times, Ralph managed to lure hundreds of my peers into the parish hall every Sunday night for something as cornball as fellowship. How'd he do it? He let us smoke. And his other ingenious invention, used probably for the first time in Christianity's 2000-year history, was that he almost never mentioned the Bible. Instead, he connived to make us discover the old Christian virtues on our own, using whatever encounter group stuff might do in a pinch, visualizations, back rubs, improvisations, storytelling, lying on the floor and going on fancy trips, blindfolded face explorations, games of self-revelation.
尽管世道险恶，拉尔夫每个周日晚上还是设法将我数百个同龄人吸引到教区大厅参加像团契这样老套的活动。他是怎么做到的？他让我们抽烟。他另一个天才发明，大概是基督教2000年历史上第一次使用，就是他几乎从不提圣经。相反，他设法让我们自己去发现古老的基督教美德，在必要时使用各种遭遇小组的手段：视觉化、背部按摩、即兴表演、讲故事、躺在地板上进行虚构旅行、蒙眼面部探索、自我揭示游戏。
At the time, we ate it up. We so longed to be emotionally intimate with one another, and Ralph had given us a language. I loved all those tricks, except one. Still to this day, the mere mention of the phrase makes me shudder, role-playing.
当时，我们全盘接受了。我们如此渴望彼此在情感上亲近，而拉尔夫给了我们一种语言。我喜欢所有这些技巧，除了一种。直到今天，提到这个短语依然让我不寒而栗：角色扮演。
Oh, we'd do things like, boy cheats on the exam and is caught at it. And he loses his scholarship. Now he has to tell his parents. That's one.
哦，我们会做一些事情，比如男孩在考试中作弊被抓。他失去了奖学金。现在他必须告诉他的父母。这是一个。
Another one was, I stole stuff at Woolworth's, and I got away with it. But now they want to give me an honor for being an outstanding Boy Scout or something. And I know the truth. And how do I deal with that?
另一个是，我在伍尔沃斯偷了东西，我逃脱了惩罚。但现在他们想给我颁发一个荣誉，因为我是杰出的童子军什么的。但我知道真相。我该如何处理这个问题？
Sure, it sounds innocent. But then came the summer of '74. There was a two-week retreat at Camp St. Christopher that almost immediately began to go kaflooey. Someone stole a boy's epilepsy medication, thinking it was Quaaludes, and another boy's father died.
当然，听起来很天真。但随后74年的夏天到了。圣克里斯托弗营地有一个为期两周的退修会，几乎立刻就开始乱套了。有人偷了一个男孩的癫痫药，以为那是安眠酮，还有另一个男孩的父亲去世了。
And then there was a racial incident, required at Bible camp in those days, that involved a black kid, who'd over-read a blond girl's expression of Christian amity. Then a bunch of tough, upstate white boys went after the black kid. And then a bunch of other elite white kids, in peace-loving liberal hippie drag, threatened to beat the snot out of the racists. The camp was a swamp of raw emotion.
接着发生了一起种族事件，那是那个年代圣经夏令营必不可少的，涉及到一个黑人孩子，他过度解读了一个金发女孩表达基督教友谊的方式。然后一群强悍的北部白人男孩追赶那个黑人孩子。接着一群其他的精英白人孩子，穿着崇尚和平的自由嬉皮服装，威胁要痛揍那些种族主义者。营地是一片原始情感的沼泽。
So Ralph brought out the big guns, in this case a camper named Mary Frances Leopold, a teenager who, in the creaky vocabulary of the '70s, was described as feisty, spirited, strident. That is, confident, capable, smart. Her assignment? Ralph had decided that nothing would galvanize the camp like a good role-playing session.
所以拉尔夫拿出了重型武器，在这种情况下，是一名叫做玛丽·弗朗西斯·利奥波德的营员，一个在70年代老掉牙的词汇里被形容为“带劲、精神、尖锐”的少女。也就是说，自信、能干、聪明。她的任务？拉尔夫决定，没有什么能比一场好的角色扮演更能激励营地了。
If you remember the way the technique worked, we put a name tag on her. And we said-- I don't remember what we called her, something like Laura Smith or something, something other than her name.
如果你还记得这项技术是如何运作的，我们在她身上贴了个名牌。我们说——我不记得我们叫她什么，类似劳拉·史密斯之类的，除了她名字以外的任何名字。
And you would introduce her at the beginning of the session.
你会在会议开始时介绍她。
That's correct. And we would create a story about this girl and tell people that she's 16 years old. She comes from Charleston. She goes to Porter-Gaud School. We would create this story and make her a real person. And then she would sit there. And then she would be that person.
没错。我们会编造一个关于这个女孩的故事，告诉人们她16岁。她来自查尔斯顿。她就读于波特-高德学校。我们会创造这个故事，把她变成一个真实的人。然后她会坐在那里。然后她就会成为那个人。
Word quickly spread at breakfast that morning that no one had seen Mary Frances. And we all noticed that no clergymen were in the cafeteria. "They've been working her over since dawn," someone said. "It's going to be big."
那天早餐时消息迅速传开，没有人见过玛丽·弗朗西斯。我们都注意到食堂里没有神职人员。“他们从黎明就开始对她进行训练了，”有人说。“这会是一场大戏。”
After breakfast, we all congregated in the rec hall. I couldn't help but notice that other ministers, not associated with the camp, were there, as if they knew something was up. The bishop was there.
早餐后，我们都聚集在娱乐大厅。我忍不住注意到其他与营地无关的牧师也在场，好像他们知道发生了什么。主教也在那里。
Ralph got up on stage and explained that Mary Frances's character, Laura Smith, was a girl who had really opened up in her small group, the little encounter groups of eight campers that met twice a day to share intimacies and do trust exercises. This character, Laura, we'd soon learn, had confided with them that she'd had an illegal abortion. And then two other people in her small group had broken the rules and gossiped the news around the camp. A couple of people had called her a slut.
拉尔夫走上台，解释说玛丽·弗朗西斯的角色，劳拉·史密斯，是一个在小组中真正敞开心扉的女孩，就是那些每天聚会两次分享隐私和进行信任练习的八人小遭遇小组。我们很快就会了解到，这个角色劳拉已经向他们坦白了她曾进行过非法堕胎。然后她小组里的另外两个人违反了规则，在营地里散布了这个消息。几个人叫她“荡妇”。
Here's how the role-playing worked. Each of the real small groups were to send up two campers to play the blabbers, whose job now was to talk to Laura as she sat at the camp office with her bags, so humiliated she had decided to leave.
这就是角色扮演的运作方式。每个真实的小组都要派出两名营员去扮演那些大嘴巴的人，他们的工作现在就是去和坐在营地办公室拿着行李的劳拉交谈，她因为太羞愧而决定离开。
She emerges through that side door in the rec hall and goes to the stage, and without so much as a word, sits in a chair. And she just looks away, and doesn't say a word. We're all looking at her, but she's not there. And now everybody is very scared.
她穿过娱乐大厅侧门走出来，走到舞台上，一声不吭地坐在一把椅子上。她只是看向别处，一个字也不说。我们都看着她，但她人不在那里。现在每个人都很害怕。
[LAUGHTER]
[笑声]
You remember, my group was the first group to send up two people. And I remember my group, the two folks go up there. And they sit in their chair.
你还记得，我的小组是第一组派出两名人员的。我记得我的小组，那两个人上台了。他们坐在椅子上。
And I think the girl was the first to try to open her mouth. She said "Now, Laura. I realize you must be hurt." And Mary Frances just whipped around. It was something out of The Exorcist, where her head seemed to do a 360.
我想是那个女孩第一个试图开口。她说：“劳拉，我知道你一定很受伤。”玛丽·弗朗西斯立刻猛地转过头。那就像《驱魔人》里的情节，她的头似乎转了360度。
And she just burst forth with just the most horrible obscenities, eyes burning, at these two people, and just "[BLEEP] you, you goddamn bastards!" And then the obscenities just continued to fly. And you never said those kinds of words in 1972 to anybody.
她突然爆发出最可怕的脏话，双眼燃烧着，冲着这两个人喊：“[消音]你，你该死的混蛋！”然后脏话就这么不断地飞出来。而在1972年，你绝对不会那样对任何人说话。
Particularly in front of the bishop.
尤其是在主教面前。
In front of the bishop, in front of all the clergy, and in front of everybody? It was unbelievable. I think those people actually backed up on the stage. I do know that in the audience, the room went electric after that. And everyone realized that going up on that stage was like marching to the guillotine.
在主教面前，在所有神职人员面前，在所有人面前？简直令人难以置信。我想那些人实际上在舞台上后退了。我知道观众席里，在那之后整个房间充满了电流。每个人都意识到走上那个舞台就像走向断头台。
It was breathtaking, nerve-wracking, stunning. Mary Frances kept switching her tactics, slaughtering every fresh couple. 10 went up, and 10 came down, utterly shaken.
那场面令人窒息、紧张、惊人。玛丽·弗朗西斯不断改变策略，宰杀每一对新人。10个人上去，10个人下来，彻底震撼。
One time, she just stared at the couple and said nothing, absolutely nothing. With the next pair, she argued logically. With the next, she collapsed and began crying scalding tears of pain. With each variation, the tension in the room grew. Whatever Ralph was trying to do with this game of pretend, to bring us together, to make us confront our guilt, to teach Christian empathy, the role-playing mainly succeeded in terrifying us.
有一次，她只是盯着那两个人，什么也没说，真的什么也没说。面对下一对，她逻辑严密地争辩。面对再下一对，她崩溃了，开始流下痛苦的滚烫泪水。随着每一次变化，房间里的紧张气氛都在加剧。无论拉尔夫试图通过这个伪装游戏做什么，是要团结我们、让我们面对内疚、教导基督教的同情心，角色扮演的主要成功之处在于让我们感到恐惧。
I tracked down Mary Frances. She's now a chemist near Silicon Valley. 25 years later, what she remembers is the aftermath of her role-playing. None of us at camp could quite get back to seeing her as just Mary Frances. So we all stayed away.
我找到了玛丽·弗朗西斯。她现在是硅谷附近的一名化学家。25年后，她记得的是她角色扮演后的余波。我们营地里的任何人都无法再把她看作只是玛丽·弗朗西斯。所以我们都避开她。
I think most of the people at camp were a bit colder. And the people who normally would have smiled and been pleasant weren't quite as smiley and pleasant. And the people who were my friends talked a little bit about it, that it had been really frightening.
我想营地里大多数人都变得冷漠了一些。那些平时会微笑和善的人不再那么爱笑和友善。而我的朋友们谈论了一点这件事，说这真的非常可怕。
As we talked about it, she corrected me on one key aspect I had got wrong. I asked her where she'd found in herself so much anger to play out Ralph's scenario. Then she straightened me out. It wasn't Ralph's scenario at all. She made it up.
当我们谈论这件事时，她纠正了我弄错的一个关键点。我问她在哪儿找到那么多愤怒来演绎拉尔夫的情节。然后她纠正了我。那根本不是拉尔夫的情节。那是她编造的。
I took it from other people's experience at camp. And it turned out that someone else there had experienced that, had had an abortion.
我借鉴了营地里其他人的经历。结果发现那里有另一个人也经历过，也堕过胎。
At this point, abortion had been legal for maybe six months or something.
当时堕胎合法化大概才六个月左右。
Well, this particular person had an illegal abortion and had talked about it at camp. And it had been gossiped about.
嗯，那个人确实进行过非法堕胎，并且在营地里谈论过。这件事被传开了。
At that session?
在那次会议上？
Yes, at that particular session.
是的，在那次特定会议上。
Can you hear my surprise? I had repressed all of this, chalking up the power of the incident to Mary Frances's quote, "great performance." But of course, what made it so powerful was that contrary to what Ralph wanted, a nice exercise in guilt and absolution that we could experience synthetically, and therefore safely, it had become something far more devastating once given over to Mary Frances's genius.
你能听到我的惊讶吗？我压抑了所有这些，把那次事件的力量归功于玛丽·弗朗西斯的“伟大表演”。但当然，让它如此震撼的原因是，与拉尔夫想要的相反——我们本可以合成地、因此安全地体验一场关于内疚与赦免的良好演习——一旦交到玛丽·弗朗西斯的天才手中，它就变得更加毁灭性。
The guilt she'd coaxed from us was real, because we all had gossiped about that girl. We all really were those two people in the role-play. It was the most transcendent of all role-plays, because there was almost no role-playing at all.
她从我们这里诱导出来的内疚是真实的，因为我们都谈论过那个女孩。我们确实就是角色扮演中的那两个人。这是所有角色扮演中最具超越性的，因为它几乎根本没有角色扮演。
[MUSIC PLAYING - "AVE MARIA" BY FRANZ SCHUBERT, SUNG BY DAME JANET BAKER]
[音乐播放 - 弗朗茨·舒伯特的《圣母颂》，由珍妮特·贝克夫人演唱]
Jack Hitt is a contributing editor to This American Life .
杰克·希特是《这一美国生活》的特约编辑。
Well, listen, Ralph. I'm going to let you get back to--
好吧，听着，拉尔夫。我要让你回去——
Praying for you.
为你祈祷。
Coming up, white suburbanites tote that barge, lift that bale, sing some old Negro spirituals, and otherwise pretend to be slaves in the old South. Why they do it, what they get out of it, and what this game of pretend is all about. That's in a minute, from Public Radio International, when our program continues.
接下来，白人郊区居民抬着驳船，扛着捆包，唱着古老的黑人灵歌，并以其他方式伪装成旧南方的奴隶。他们为什么要这样做，他们从中得到了什么，以及这个伪装游戏到底是怎么回事。一分钟后，节目继续，来自国际公共广播电台。
It's This American Life. I'm Ira Glass. Each week on our program, of course, we choose a theme, bring you a variety of different stories on that theme. Today's program, Be Careful Who You Pretend to Be, cautionary tales about games of pretend that backfire. We have arrived at Act Three of our program. Act Three, What's So Funny About Peace, Love, and Understanding?
这里是《这一美国生活》。我是艾拉·格拉斯。每周节目中，我们当然会选择一个主题，为您带来关于该主题的各种故事。今天的节目是：“小心你所伪装的人”，关于伪装游戏适得其反的警示故事。我们已经到达节目的第三幕。第三幕，“和平、爱与理解有什么可笑的？”
The idea is simple. We Midwestern suburbanites will not simply learn history. We will live history. We will become 19th century runaway slaves. And for close to two hours, we will face their enemies. We will feel their fear. We will think their thoughts.
这个想法很简单。我们中西部的郊区居民不会仅仅学习历史。我们要生活在历史中。我们要成为19世纪逃亡的奴隶。在近两个小时的时间里，我们将面对他们的敌人。我们将感受他们的恐惧。我们将思考他们的想法。
Then, when we drive back to our suburban homes, we will carry a small part of them back with us. And maybe this will teach us to think more kindly about our neighbors, or more carefully about ourselves, or both. This is the idea. It says so in the promotional material.
然后，当我们开车回到郊区的家时，我们会带回他们的一小部分。也许这会教导我们更友善地对待邻居，或更审慎地对待自己，或两者兼而有之。这是这个想法。宣传材料上就是这么写的。
This is the program that Ron Copeland, the guy back in our first act, works for. It's called Follow the North Star at the Conner Prairie Living History Museum, outside of Indianapolis, 1,400 acres with a small town, some forest, assorted barns and cabins and outbuildings, and dozens of performers in costume who are called historical interpreters. The program takes place at night, a sort of simulation of the Underground Railroad. This American Life produce Alix Spiegel wanted to find out what it is that people actually get out of this game of pretend. So she joined in.
这就是罗恩·科普兰，我们第一幕提到的那个人，所工作的项目。它被称为“跟随北极星”，位于印第安纳波利斯郊外的康纳草原生活历史博物馆，占地1400英亩，有一个小镇、一些森林、各式各样的谷仓和棚屋及外屋，还有几十名穿着戏服的表演者，被称为历史讲解员。节目在晚上进行，是一种地下铁路的模拟。这一美国生活制片人艾丽克斯·斯皮格尔想弄清楚人们到底从这个伪装游戏中得到了什么。所以她也参加了。
We are here to be abused, humiliated, degraded, verbally and physically punished. But before we get down to the business of being brutalized and reduced to nothing, we are briefed by a small woman in colonial dress who wants very much to impress upon us the serious nature of this program. She tells us it will be difficult. There will be language. It will be physically demanding. We will be pushed and shoved and made to kneel down or lie on our stomachs. Then she asks if there are any questions.
我们在这里是为了被虐待、羞辱、贬低，在言语和身体上受到惩罚。但在我们开始被残暴对待并缩减为一无所有的过程之前，我们被一个身穿殖民服装的矮小妇女进行了简报，她非常想让我们印象深刻地了解这个项目的严肃性。她告诉我们这将是非常艰难的。会有粗口。在体力上会有要求。我们将被推搡，被迫跪下或趴在肚子上。然后她问有没有任何问题。
Yes, young lady.
有，年轻女士。
Do you suggest that we spit out our gum so we don't choke or anything?
您建议我们吐掉口香糖以免噎着什么的吗？
Yes.
是的。
For a group of people facing 90 continuous minutes of abuse, we are in a remarkably upbeat mood. On the guided walk out to the first stop of the program, everyone's chattering, laughing, ready to wheel hell out of the driveway and take her for a spin.
对于一群即将面临连续90分钟虐待的人来说，我们情绪出奇地高昂。在前往项目第一站的引导路线上，大家都在闲聊、大笑，准备好要带着这个经历去兜风。
I think it's going to be fun.
我觉得这会很有趣。
I think it's going to be fun, but it's going to be scary.
我觉得这会很有趣，但会很可怕。
Do you guys want to be scared?
你们想被吓到吗？
They could yell at us. I don't care about that.
他们可以对我们大喊大叫。我不在乎那个。
I want it to be intense so we know what they went through.
我想要它很强烈，这样我们才能知道他们经历了什么。
Although I've been told by the people running Follow the North Star that an equal number of black and white patrons attend the program, the people in my group are mostly white and mostly women. The tone of the group is dominated by five 13-year-old girls, Sadie, Amanda, Rachel, Trish, and Britney, all friends from the same junior high school who read about the program in the paper and came because it sounded neat.
虽然运行“跟随北极星”的人告诉我，黑人和白人顾客参加该项目的比例相等，但我这组的人大多是白人，而且大多是女性。小组的基调由五个13岁女孩主导：萨迪、阿曼达、瑞秋、翠西和布兰妮，她们都是同一所初中的朋友，在报纸上读到这个项目，觉得听起来很酷就来了。
Then there's Linda, a blond-haired mother of two, who has brought her husband and two teenage children to the program because she feels it's important for them to have a learning experience, and Henry, who wears a long trench coat and identifies himself as a lover of history. There is Louise, a 34-year-old Quaker woman whose ancestors were part of the Underground Railroad, three 16-year-olds who are studying the Civil War, a handful of other adults, and finally, there's Pete and Alexander, the only African-Americans in the group, both in baseball caps and light-colored jeans, who are here, they say, to observe everyone else.
还有琳达，一个有两个孩子的金发母亲，她带了丈夫和两个十几岁的孩子来参加，因为她觉得让他们有这种学习经历很重要；亨利，穿着长风衣，自称是历史爱好者。还有露易丝，一个34岁的贵格会女性，她的祖先是地下铁路的一部分，三个正在研究内战的16岁少年，还有几个其他成年人，最后是皮特和亚历山大，组里仅有的两个非裔美国人，都戴着棒球帽和浅色牛仔裤，他们说来这里是为了观察其他人。
Our guide leads us to the top of a hill, a small hump of land overlooking a dark valley. At the base of the hill, we can see the flicker of a bonfire. But beyond that, nothing, just the random black wilderness. We stand and ponder it for a minute while our guide gives us parting instructions. "Please refrain from attacking the interpreters." Then it's time to meet our master.
我们的向导带我们到一个山顶，一个小土丘俯瞰着一个黑暗的山谷。在山脚下，我们可以看到篝火的闪烁。但除此之外，什么也没有，只是随机的黑色荒野。我们站着沉思了一会儿，向导给了我们临别指示。“请避免攻击讲解员。”现在是时候去见我们的主人了。
I want the bucks over here on the right side. I want the breeders over on the left side. Now move.
“我要壮丁们到右边来。我要繁育者们到左边去。现在动起来。”
At the bottom of the hill, four men in costumes surround us and start screaming. Everything is chaos. Before I know what's happening, the lover of history is lying face-down in the grass, his arms spread wide like Jesus. And the mother of two who felt her children needed an educational experience is on her knees, head down, blinking out at the ground, while her son stands 10 feet away with the rest of the men being, you know, educated.
在山脚下，四个穿着戏服的人围住我们并开始尖叫。一切都是混乱的。在我还没明白发生了什么之前，那个历史爱好者已经脸朝下躺在草地上，双臂像耶稣一样张开。而那个觉得孩子需要教育经验的两个孩子的母亲正跪在地上，低下头，眨眼看着地面，而她的儿子站在10英尺外，和男人们一起——你知道——受教育。
Don't look at me. You don't ever look at me.
“别看我。你永远不准看我。”
Yes, sir.
“是的，长官。”
What's your trade, boy? What's your trade? Answer me. Get down on your knees. What about you, boy? You got a trade?
“你的职业是什么，男孩？你的职业是什么？回答我。跪下。那你呢，男孩？你有职业吗？”
I like to work with metal.
“我喜欢从事金属工作。”
Work with metal? You a blacksmith, boy?
“金属工作？你是个铁匠吗，男孩？”
Yes, sir.
“是的，长官。”
Tell me, what be a hardy? What be a hardy, boy? You ain't no blacksmith. Get down there on your knees with that liar right there.
“告诉我，什么是‘Hardy’？什么是‘Hardy’，男孩？你根本不是铁匠。和那个骗子一起跪下。”
Let's see your hand, boy. You got gloves on. How can I see your hand when you got gloves on? Get them gloves off.
“让我看看你的手，男孩。你戴着手套。当你戴着手套时我怎么看你的手？把手套摘了。”
The girls stand in silence, too scared to move. Their heads are down. Their eyes are lowered, staring out at some invisible point just beyond and below their noses.
女孩们沉默地站着，吓得不敢动弹。她们的头低着。她们的眼睛垂着，盯着鼻子前方和下方某个看不见的点。
One of the masters snakes his way from girl to girl, working them over. He leans in close with his lantern, so they can feel the heat of the flame on their faces, then starts screaming. Two of the girls begin to shake. Their lips tremble. Another girl ties on her white headband, a signal to the slave masters that she can't take it, and steps sideways out of line.
其中一个主人像蛇一样在女孩之间穿梭，对她们进行训练。他凑近了，举着灯笼，让她们能感觉到火焰的热度，然后开始尖叫。两个女孩开始发抖。她们的嘴唇颤抖。另一个女孩系上了她的白色头带，这是一个给奴隶主发出的信号，表示她承受不住了，并退出了队列。
How old you be?
“你多大了？”
13.
“13岁。”
13. Well, you's bein' a good breeder, then. We probably get 9 or 10 out of you, you know that? Sell them off, there, we could make us a lot of money.
“13岁。嗯，那你是个很好的繁育者。我们大概能从你身上弄出9或10个孩子，你知道吗？把他们卖了，我们就发财了。”
Are you looking up? Are you looking up?
“你在抬头吗？你在抬头吗？”
No.
“没有。”
No, what?
“没有，什么？”
No, sir.
“没有，长官。”
Then you say sir. Every time a white man talks to you, you answer him sir. You understand me?
“那你得叫长官。每次白人跟你说话，你都要回答他‘长官’。明白吗？”
Yes, sir.
“是的，长官。”
It's surprisingly effective, a kind of collective hallucination so brutal and bizarre it makes you conscious of every detail around you. You notice the flattened blades of wet grass, the bluish tint of rubber on your shoe, the shadows of the fire, the acid smell of lantern fluid, the fold and texture of a scarf tucked into the coat of the person in front of you.
这出奇地有效，这是一种集体的幻觉，如此残暴而离奇，让你意识到周围的每一个细节。你注意到压平的湿草叶，鞋上橡胶的蓝绿色调，火光的阴影，灯笼油的酸味，前面那个人外套里塞着的围巾的褶皱和纹理。
Get your eyes down, you understand? Answer me. Was that you?
“把眼睛低下去，明白吗？回答我。那是你吗？”
Finally, the masters get tired of yelling and corral us into a single-file line. One of the masters leaves the other behind to march us up a hill. He's waving his gun like a flag and barking out orders. "Stay in line. Keep your eyes down. March faster. March slower." And perhaps most frightening of all, "Sing."
终于，主人们厌倦了吼叫，把我们赶进了一个单列排队。其中一个主人把另一个人留在后面，带着我们行军上山。他挥舞着枪像挥舞旗帜一样，并大声下达命令。“保持队列。眼睛低着。走快点。走慢点。”而也许最令人恐惧的是，“唱歌”。
Sing. Sing.
唱歌。唱歌。
[MUSIC PLAYING - "SWING LOW, SWEET CHARIOT"]
[音乐播放 - 《Swing Low, Sweet Chariot》]
In this context, the absurdity of white, suburban teenagers in Nikes singing Negro spirituals is actually kind of touching. They march up the hill singing shyly. And at the top of the hill, there's a waist-high pile of wood. And then 20 feet away, there's a tree. And our master instructs the women to carry the wood from the pile to the tree one piece at a time, and then instructs the men to move the wood back from the tree to the pile two pieces at a time.
在这种语境下，白人郊区少年穿着耐克鞋唱着黑人灵歌的荒诞感其实有点感人。他们害羞地唱着歌爬上山。在山顶，有一堆齐腰高的木头。而在20英尺外，有一棵树。我们的主人指示女人们把木头从那堆搬到那棵树，每次一块，然后指示男人们把木头从树那里搬回那一堆，每次两块。
Now get to it. Get moving. Come on, quicker, quicker.
“现在开始。动起来。快点，快点。”
One of the 16-year-old girls stumbles, and the master pulls her out of the group and tells her to stand by him.
其中一个16岁的女孩跌倒了，主人把她从人群中拉出来，叫她站在他身边。
Come here. Now I know you can yell. Let me hear you yell. Let me hear you yell.
“过来。我知道你能叫。让我听到你叫。让我听到你叫。”
What do you want me to yell, sir?
“您想让我叫什么，长官？”
Just yell. Just yell.
“随便叫。随便叫。”
Aaah.
“啊——”
Tell them to move the wood.
“告诉他们搬木头。”
Move the wood!
“搬木头！”
Louder.
“大声点。”
Move the wood!
“搬木头！”
Come here. Don't worry. Keep yelling at them.
“过来。别担心。继续对着他们叫。”
Move the wood!
“搬木头！”
Now I'm going to go back and check on my friend. And if I come back and you're gone, I'll shoot you in the leg. So keep yelling at them. Keep them moving.
“现在我要回去看看我的朋友。如果我回来时你不见了，我就朝你的腿开枪。所以继续对着他们叫。让他们动起来。”
Move the wood.
“搬木头。”
Louder.
“大声点。”
Move the wood!
“搬木头！”
Keep them moving. I want to be able to hear you.
“让他们动起来。我要能听到你的声音。”
Move the wood. Move the wood! Move the wood! Move the wood! Move the wood. Move the wood!
“搬木头。搬木头！搬木头！搬木头！搬木头。搬木头！”
Now abandoned by our slavemasters, alone on the top of a hill in the middle of the night, with a 10th-grader acting as overseer, we continue to move the wood from the pile to the tree and back again. No one makes a break for it. There's no revolt, not even the hint of resistance. We're broken. It's taken 15 minutes.
现在我们被奴隶主抛弃了，独自在深夜的山顶，由一个10年级学生充当监工，我们继续把木头从堆搬到树，再搬回去。没有人逃跑。没有暴动，甚至没有反抗的迹象。我们崩溃了。用了15分钟。
Hurry up. Hurry up.
“快点。快点。”
Finally, our work is interrupted by a white woman in a full-length prairie skirt and bonnet who appears out of the darkness, another historic interpreter. She leads us into her barn and berates us at length, the main thrust of her tirade being that we are stupid and slovenly and should probably be sent back to Africa. But in between insults, she manages to drop a series of useful survival tips for the runaway slave.
最后，我们的工作被一个穿着全长草原裙和帽子的白人妇女打断，她从黑暗中出现，那是另一个历史讲解员。她把我们带进她的谷仓，喋喋不休地训斥了我们很久，她长篇大论的主要内容是我们愚蠢而邋遢，可能应该被送回非洲。但在侮辱之间，她设法丢出了一系列有用的逃亡奴隶求生技巧。
Seek out Quakers. They will help you. Look for handkerchiefs tied to doorknobs or burning candles in windows. Those are signs that a Quaker is within. Always send one person ahead to ask if they are a friend of a friend. That's the password, "friend of a friend."
“寻找贵格会教徒。他们会帮你们。寻找门把手上系着手帕或窗户里燃着蜡烛的房子。那些是贵格会教徒在里面的标志。永远派一个人先去问他们是否是‘朋友的朋友’。那是密码，‘朋友的朋友’。”
Then she leads us through a small wood to a dirt road which winds its way along a cornfield, points down the road, and tells us to look for a small cabin with a light in its window. We tell her thank you. She tells us get off her land. And the group moves down the road.
然后她带我们穿过一片小树林来到一条沿着玉米地的土路，指着路下方，告诉我们寻找一间窗户有灯光的小棚屋。我们说谢谢。她告诉我们离开她的地盘。小组沿路走下去。
How are you guys doing?
你们觉得怎么样？
Scary. It's naturally scary.
可怕。这本身就很可怕。
You don't want someone pushing you around.
你不想让人推搡你。
I know. It's like they get all up in you.
我知道。就像他们全压在你身上。
This is how it was in real life. This is how it was. And I feel so sorry for those people.
现实生活中就是这样。确实是这样。我真为那些人感到难过。
I'm just happy that there were people that actually helped along.
我很高兴确实有人在路上帮助过。
I know.
我知道。
Then I catch up to Pete and Alexander, the only two black guys in the group.
然后我赶上了皮特和亚历山大，组里仅有的两个黑人伙伴。
How are you guys doing?
你们觉得怎么样？
It's not as intense as I thought it was going to be.
没有我想象中那么强烈。
Really? Do you want it to be more intense?
真的吗？你们想要它更强烈吗？
Yeah.
是的。
We jog down the road. In the distance to the left of the road, maybe 500 feet ahead, is a campfire. We can see the outline of a small girl in the shadow of the fire. She's calling out to us, motioning with her arms for us to come to her. But the group hangs back, not sure how to respond. Then out of the bushes, a man with a gun. It's a trap.
我们沿着路慢跑。在路左边的远处，大概前面500英尺处，有一个篝火。我们能在火影中看到一个小女孩的轮廓。她对我们呼喊，用手臂挥动示意我们过去。但小组退缩了，不确定该如何回应。然后从灌木丛里跳出来一个拿枪的男人。这是个陷阱。
Hold on right there.
“就在那儿别动。”
[GUNSHOT]
[枪声]
[SCREAMING]
[尖叫声]
We book. 19 Midwestern suburbanites cum runaways set loose in the Indiana wilderness with no apparent chaperone are running for their lives as if, well, as if something actually depended on it. In the night air, with my tape recorder bouncing a bruise into my hip, trying like hell to keep up with 13-year-olds, the wind on my microphone screwing up all hope of decent production values, I feel excited and, perversely, more free than I have in a long, long time. It's not clear what we should do or where we should go or who we should trust, and this is perhaps the best part. I find myself giggling uncontrollably and realize that the idea that this simulation is about being transported out of my modern self and into a more authentic experience of slavery has completely evaporated.
我们逃跑了。19个中西部的郊区居民变成了逃亡奴隶，在印第安纳的荒野中被放逐，没有明显的护送者，正在为生命奔跑，就好像……就好像确实有什么事取决于此。在夜空中，我的录音机撞击着我的胯部，拼命试图跟上13岁的孩子们，风声在我的麦克风上破坏了所有良好制作价值的希望，我感到兴奋，且反常地，比很长一段时间以来都要自由。不清楚我们该做什么，去哪里，或者该相信谁，这也许是最好的部分。我发现自己忍不住咯咯笑，意识到这个模拟是为了将我从现代自我中转移出来，进入一个更真实的奴隶体验的想法已经完全烟消云散了。
Now it is not about understanding slavery. It's about survival in an uncertain world, where people leap out at you and try to abuse you. It's an old-fashioned race from the bogeyman, who is waiting behind every tree.
现在，这不再是关于理解奴隶制了。这是关于在一个充满不确定性的世界中生存，人们跳出来试图虐待你。这是一种老式的从“妖怪”那里逃跑的比赛，它就在每棵树后面等待。
Oh, gosh. Oh my gosh. I can't breathe. I can't breathe.
“哦，天哪。哦，天哪。我不能呼吸了。我不能呼吸了。”
I was running faster than I've ever run in my life.
我跑得比我这辈子跑得任何时候都要快。
Shhh, now be quiet.
“嘘，安静点。”
There it is. there it is. There it is.
“就在那里。就在那里。就在那里。”
Our random, breathless flight deposits us exactly where the planners of this reenactment want us, 50 feet from a cabin with a candle in its window, refuge. The cabin is up a steep hill, so we congregate at the bottom, then send up a representative, Britney, to test the waters.
我们随意、气喘吁吁的飞行把我们带到了重演计划者想要我们将到的地方，离一个窗户上有蜡烛的棚屋50英尺远，那是避难所。棚屋在一个陡峭的山坡上，所以我们在底部聚集，然后派出一个代表，布兰妮，去试探情况。
One person. What's the password?
“一个人。密码是什么？”
Friend of a friend.
“朋友的朋友。”
Britney, Britney, Britney.
布兰妮，布兰妮，布兰妮。
Would you like a drink?
你想要喝水吗？
Thank you.
谢谢。
You are most welcome.
非常欢迎。
Can you help us?
你能帮我们吗？
You will get all the help thee needs.
你会得到你所需要的一切帮助。
Inside the cabin, a tall man who looks like a slimmed-down version of that guy on the Quaker Oats box pours us cold water from a tin pitcher, passes out flat circles of cornbread that look like small, yellow hockey pucks, and gives us a short history of Quakers and Quakerism, elementary-school-play-style. We all sit cross-legged on the dirt floor, looking grateful and chewing hard on the cornbread. Then his wife gets up and tells us that their son, Moses, who's been warming himself by the fire, will escort us through town to safety.
棚屋里，一个高个男人，看起来就像贵格会燕麦盒上那个人的瘦身版，从锡罐里给我们倒了凉水，分发看起来像小块黄色冰球的平坦玉米饼，并给我们简要介绍了一番贵格会及其主义，就像小学戏剧风格。我们全盘腿坐在泥地上，神情感激地嚼着坚硬的玉米饼。然后他的妻子起身告诉我们，他们的儿子摩西，一直在火边取暖，将护送我们穿过小镇到达安全地带。
There is another family in these parts. Their name is Ward. They are from North Carolina. And they are colored folk like thee. I would suggest that thee seek out folks such as them. Should slavehunters come through these parts, they will not know thee from the locals. May God be with thee as thee travel.
这附近还有另一个家庭。他们姓沃德。他们来自北卡罗来纳州。他们和你一样是黑人。我会建议你寻找像他们这样的人。如果有奴隶猎人来到这附近，他们无法把你们和当地人区分开。愿上帝在你旅行时与你同在。
Travel with Moses through the town. Stay together as a group and travel silently. God be with you, friends. God be with you.
和摩西一起穿过小镇旅行。作为一个团队保持在一起，静静地旅行。愿上帝与你们同在，朋友们。愿上帝与你们同在。
Describe what's going on now. Describe what this looks like.
描述一下现在发生了什么。描述一下这看起来像什么。
There's a really big white house with a light on. And there's some kind of cabin that's brown and has no lights on. And we're walking through this big path with trees surrounding us. And there's--
有一栋非常大的白房子，亮着灯。还有某种棚屋，是棕色的，没有灯光。我们正在穿过这条周围环绕着树木的大路。还有——
Hold on there.
在那儿站住。
[LAUGHTER]
[笑声]
My, my, my. Lookie what we've got here.
哎呀，哎呀，看看我们得到了什么。
The laughing man leads us into his store, a narrow room with a dark wood counter that smells heavily of wax, and picks up a thick leather riding whip. He walks over to one of the girls, then starts to slowly stroke her hair with the whip, from the top of her head down the length of her face, then under her hair to the skin on her neck. He's got a big wad of tobacco stuffed in his cheek, and he keeps spitting it at our feet.
那个大笑的男人领我们进入他的商店，一间有着深色木柜台的狭窄房间，弥漫着浓重的蜡味，拿起一条厚皮马鞭。他走到其中一个女孩身边，开始用鞭子慢慢抚摸她的头发，从头顶一直到脸的长度，然后从头发下面划向脖子上的皮肤。他的腮里塞着一大块烟草，不断往我们脚下吐口水。
Ain't you tired of being out there, all that running and hiding and everything, hmm? Ain't you, hmm?
“在那儿跑来跑去，躲躲藏藏，感觉很累吧，嗯？是不是，嗯？”
No, sir.
“没有，长官。”
Mm-hmm. Hmm. Hmph. What about you, little one, hmm? You want to get back with your kin down there, hmm? Want to get back with your kin?
“唔。嗯。哼。那你呢，小家伙，嗯？想回到那边的亲人身边吗，嗯？想回到亲人身边吗？”
No, sir.
“没有，长官。”
Don't care about them at all? Hmm? Don't you want to do that? All you need to do is tell me what your master's name was down there. And old Ben will get you right back there.
“根本不在乎他们吗？嗯？不想那样吗？你所要做的就是告诉我你原来的主人叫什么名字。老本会把你送回去的。”
You want to get back with your folks again, don't you there, little one, hmm? Old Ben's just trying to help you, you know that? You going to tell me, hmm?
“你确实想回到家人身边，不是吗，小家伙，嗯？老本只是想帮你，你知道吗？你愿意告诉我吗，嗯？”
No, sir.
“没有，长官。”
Mm-hmm. Mm-hmm.
“唔。唔。”
The man with the whip decides that he's going to take us down South to sell us. Then Moses, the Quaker boy who is supposed to be helping us, decides that he's going to get the authorities and sic them on the man with the whip. Then the man with the whip decides that he's going to put his fist through Moses's face.
那个拿鞭子的男人决定要把我们卖到南方。然后摩西，那个本该帮助我们的贵格会男孩，决定要叫当局来对付那个拿鞭子的男人。然后拿鞭子的男人决定要一拳打在摩西脸上。
This seems to impress Moses, and he offers to give the man with the whip $10 in gold coin to let us go free. The man with the whip decides that he likes this offer, with one exception. He pulls out one of the girls from the group and draws her body close to his. She's young, not more than 16, and looks genuinely terrified.
这似乎震慑了摩西，他提议给拿鞭子的男人10块金币放我们自由。拿鞭子的男人决定他喜欢这个提议，有一个例外。他从人群中拉出一个女孩，把她的身体拉近自己。她很年轻，不超过16岁，看起来真的吓坏了。
Tell you what I'm going to do for you, boy. I'm inclined to be interested in your offer a little bit, being alone by myself. This one here looks like she please me quite a bit. Tell you what I'll do for you. I'll take your $10. You get this whole bunch out of here. And I keep this one here to comfort me.
“告诉你我为你要做什么，男孩。我倾向于对你的提议感兴趣，我自己一个人。这个看起来很讨我喜欢。告诉你我为你要做什么。我拿走你的10块钱。你带这群人滚蛋。我留着这一个来安慰我。”
No, no, it's $10 for all of them.
“不，不，那是所有人的10块钱。”
No, that's the way it's going to be.
“不，事情就是这样。”
There's no deal.
“没得谈。”
Boy, you don't understand. It's the $10. And I'll keep this wench. And you get this rest of this rabble out of here right now. Or I'll blow your damn brains out.
“男孩，你不懂。就是10块钱。我留着这娘们。你带着剩下的这群人立刻滚蛋。否则我就打烂你的脑浆。”
Get them out of here right now. Do it right now. Do it right now.
“立刻把他们弄走。现在就做。现在就做。”
The girl stands stricken while the rest of the group is pushed out the back door. At first, the group takes off running, but we come up short about 200 feet into the forest.
女孩站在那里惊呆了，而小组其他人被推向后门。起初，小组跑开了，但我们在森林里大概跑了200英尺后停了下来。
Wait. We're supposed to be a group.
等一下。我们应该是一个团队。
Back.
回来。
Let's go back.
回去。
I'm going back. Come on.
我要回去。快点。
Going back to get the girl is not supposed to be part of this simulation. We're supposed to debate whether or not to go back, weigh the moral choices, and realize that our survival means leaving people behind. There's a museum plant in the group, a man posing as a member of the paying public whose job is to keep us on track. He keeps telling the group to go, to forget about the girl. He gets nowhere.
回去救那个女孩本来不应该是这个模拟的一部分。我们本应该辩论是否回去，权衡道德选择，并意识到我们的生存意味着把人抛在后面。组里有一个博物馆派来的人，一个伪装成付费公众成员的男人，他的工作是让我们保持在轨道上。他不断告诉团队离开，忘记那个女孩。但他什么也没做到。
Stay as a group. And forget. She's gone. Let's go.
“作为一个团队呆着。然后忘记。她走了。走吧。”
How do we know she's gone?
你怎么知道她走了？
You bring us all down because you're rushing ahead of everyone all the time.
你们总是抢在所有人前面，把我们都拖垮了。
We have to go get her.
我们必须去救她。
Together. Together.
一起。一起。
This is the closest any of us get to a real test of what sort of slaves we'd be. And Pete and Alexander decide to be heroes. They head back into the woods to save the girl, leaving the rest of the group behind to cower by some bushes. But about 50 feet into our insurrection, a man in costume with a large gun appears out of the forest, as if by magic, another museum worker, invisibly tracking the group's progress, intent on squashing the baby revolution in its cradle.
这是我们中任何人最接近真正测试自己会成为什么样的奴隶的机会。皮特和亚历山大决定当英雄。他们转身回到森林去救那个女孩，把小组剩下的其他人留在灌木丛边畏缩。但在我们叛乱大概50英尺后，一个穿着戏服拿着大枪的男人像魔法一样出现在森林里，这是另一个博物馆工作人员，隐形地跟踪小组进度，意图在摇篮里扼杀这场微小的革命。
Back that way. Back that way.
“退回去。退回去。”
We can't do that, sir.
我们不能那样做，长官。
It will be OK. Back that way.
没事的。退回去。
Less than five minutes later, the girl rejoins us. She slips quietly into the group at the next stop, smiling sheepishly and saying that she escaped. In another 10 minutes, we're at the last stop of the program, in front of an old man in a long, black coat, black hat and black boots, who stands a foot and a half above us on a porch. He looks down on us for a bit, then picks up his cane and walks slowly from one of us to the next, touching us softly on the shoulder and telling us what is to befall us.
不到五分钟后，女孩重新加入了我们。她在下一站静静地滑进人群，羞涩地笑着说她逃出来了。又过了10分钟，我们到了项目的最后一站，站在一个穿着黑色长风衣、黑帽子、黑靴子的老人面前，他站在门廊上，比我们高出一英尺半。他低头看着我们一会儿，然后拿起拐杖，慢慢地从一个人走到另一个人身边，轻轻摸摸我们的肩膀，告诉我们将要发生什么。
You and you and you back there, you go to Cincinnati. And you blend in with the folks there in Cincinnati and live a long and successful life. Now you and you, you get caught by the slave hunters, taken down to Georgia, and sold to work in the rice fields. You don't make it. You drown crossing the river.
你和你还有你，你们去辛辛那提。和辛辛那提的人混在一起，过着长久而成功的生活。现在你和你，你们被奴隶猎人抓住了，被带到佐治亚州，卖到稻田里工作。你们没撑过去。你们过河时淹死了。
Well, I get to live.
好吧，我活下来了。
I'm predicted on being sold and taken to Georgia and working in the rice fields for the rest of my life.
我被预言会被卖掉带到佐治亚州，在稻田里工作一辈子。
Rachel's sold and gets taken to Georgia.
瑞秋被卖掉并被带到了佐治亚州。
We walk out onto a broad dirt path into the artificial white light of the museum. We're directed into a debriefing room, where there are two long tables of ginger cookies and juice in flowered Dixie cups, food for the recovering slave. There are about 20 other people in the room, other slaves from other groups, who feel the need to sit and talk about their experience.
我们走上一条宽阔的泥路，进入博物馆的人造白光中。我们被引导到一个简报室，那里有两张放着姜饼和迪克西花纸杯果汁的长桌，那是给康复奴隶的食物。房间里还有大约20个人，来自其他小组的其他奴隶，他们觉得有必要坐下来谈论他们的经历。
I circulate, asking everyone I see who they think they would have been if they had actually been born during this period. And the answer, maybe not surprisingly, is always the same, whether the person I'm talking to is black or white. I would be a hero. This means different things for the different races. For the African-Americans in the group, it means that they would have fought being a slave.
我环顾四周，问我看到的每个人如果他们真的出生在这个时期，他们认为自己会是谁。答案，也许并不令人惊讶，总是相同的，无论我交谈的对象是黑人还是白人。我会是英雄。这意味着对不同种族有不同的意义。对于小组中的非裔美国人，这意味着他们会抗争奴隶身份。
I'd definitely fight. I'd probably end up getting killed.
我绝对会战斗。我最后可能会被杀。
I would be pretty rebellious. I would be the one to try to run away.
我会非常叛逆。我会是那个试图逃跑的人。
There's no way someone's going to whip me. I don't care if-- I can't see it happening.
不可能有人鞭打我。我不在乎如果——我看不到这种情况发生。
I'd be the person either teaching or Harriet Tubman. Or I'd be chased down.
我会是那个教学的，或者成为哈里特·塔布曼。或者我会遭到追捕。
You would be really rebellious.
你真的会很叛逆吗？
Would I be? Yes.
会吗？是的。
I just know that I wouldn't last very long. I would probably be shot or hung.
我只知道我坚持不了太久。我可能会被枪杀或绞死。
Because?
因为？
Because I would try to save my family as much as I could.
因为我会尽可能拯救我的家人。
It's hard for any of us to imagine ourselves on the wrong side of history, in the past or in the present. All the whites in the program except one said that they would have fought slavery if they had lived during this time.
对于我们中的任何人来说，想象自己处于历史的错误一边是很难的，无论是在过去还是现在。项目中除一人外，所有白人都说如果他们生活在那个时代，他们会对抗奴隶制。
I would definitely help blacks to get away. I just can't stand to see people mistreated.
我绝对会帮助黑人逃跑。我只是无法忍受看到人们被虐待。
God put them on this Earth for a reason.
上帝让他们来到这个地球是有原因的。
So there's no question in your own head that you guys would be on the right side.
所以你们自己心里一点疑问都没有，你们会站在正确的一边。
None.
一点也没有。
I would be a conductor on the Underground Railroad and actually help people go out and do it. And I could see how some people would be a little bit more timid, like the family who was just in their house. And people came to them. And they huddled them in their house for a while and then let them go. I would go with the people.
我会是地下铁路的列车长，并实际帮助人们去做这件事。我能看出有些人会稍微胆小一点，就像刚才在他们家里的那一家人。人们来到他们那里。他们把人们在家里藏了一会儿，然后让他们走了。我会和这些人一起走。
We hold firm to our fantasies about ourselves, even when they are contradicted by actual experience. Ricky Murphy is an African-American man who went out with one of the earlier groups, and like the 16-year-old in my group, was made to act as overseer. In the debriefing room, I catch him laughing about how hard he was on his fellow slaves.
我们坚定地坚持着对自己的幻想，即使当它们被实际经验所矛盾时。瑞奇·墨菲是一位和早期小组一起去的非裔美国人，像我小组里的那个16岁孩子一样，被迫充当监工。在简报室，我抓到他在笑着谈论他对同伴奴隶有多苛刻。
Who asked me? Who asked me why was I the chosen one to give all the orders? Somebody got pretty pissed out there. I was like, "Come on, move the logs, I said." And I wouldn't look up. I was just, "Move the logs. Just move them. He's getting pissed. Move."
谁问我？谁问我为什么我是那个被选中去发号施令的人？外面有人相当火大。我当时就像：“来吧，搬木头，我说的。”我没抬头。我只是，“搬木头。搬它们。他火大了。搬。”
Later, I sit on a bench and talk to Ricky and his wife, Sharon. And when I ask him who he thinks he would have been if he had lived during this period, his answer is the same as the other African-Americans. I would have been rebellious. I would have been bad. So I remind him of his behavior this very night, that after 20 minutes of abuse, he could hardly bring himself to look up, turned on his own people, and concerned himself only with pleasing his master. And this surprises him.
后来，我坐在长椅上和瑞奇以及他的妻子莎伦交谈。当我问他如果生活在那个时期他认为自己会是谁时，他的回答和其他非裔美国人一样。我会很叛逆。我会很坏。所以我提醒他今晚的行为，在受虐待20分钟后，他几乎无法抬头看一眼，转而对付他自己的人民，只关心如何取悦他的主人。这让他很惊讶。
I didn't even realize it had happened until now that I'm looking back on it. But when I think about it, yeah.
我甚至没有意识到发生了什么，直到现在我回顾它的时候。但当我想到它时，是的。
He yelled at me.
他对我吼叫。
It went straight to my head. I was like, "Hey, y'all get your damn logs over here." And it was wrong.
它直接进了我的头脑。我当时就像，“嘿，你们都把那该死的木头弄过来。”这是错的。
We are careless in who we pretend to be. We are unrealistic. We're dreamers. We pretend things about ourselves, and then we mistake them for reality.
我们对于伪装成谁很粗心。我们是不现实的。我们是梦想家。我们对自己进行伪装，然后把它们误认为现实。
And these days, there are more and more of these simulated experiences. We can pretend that we are frontier mountain men from the 1740s, or World War I doughboy fighters, or someone from the Middle Ages. White South Africans can even go to a simulated Zulu village and pretend that they are tribal members.
如今，这种模拟体验越来越多。我们可以假装我们是1740年代的边疆山民，或者一战的美国大兵，或者中世纪的人。南非白人甚至可以去一个模拟的祖鲁村落，假装他们是部落成员。
So we'll dress in the clothing of Elizabethan royalty. We'll lie down in Civil War trenches with the Tennessee Valley Battalion. We'll fasten slave chains to our wrists and run screaming through the woods. Maybe one day, we'll even lie down in ovens. We will play at lives which we know, and on a deeper level, we hope and pray will never be or even resemble our own. And then inevitably, we will go home.
所以我们要穿上伊丽莎白时代的皇室服装。我们要躺在田纳西谷营的内战战壕里。我们要把奴隶锁链扣在手腕上，尖叫着穿过树林。也许有一天，我们甚至会躺在烤炉里。我们要扮演那些我们所知道的——在更深层面上，我们祈祷永远不会成为或甚至接近我们自己生活——的生活。然后不可避免地，我们要回家。
Alix Spiegel.
艾丽克斯·斯皮格尔。
Well, our program was produced today by Alix Spiegel and myself with Nancy Updike and Julie Snyder, contributing editors Paul Tough, Jack Hitt, Margie Rochlin, and Consigliere Sarah Vowell. Production help form Emi Takahara, Todd Bachmann, and Sylvia Lemus.
好的，我们今天的节目由艾丽克斯·斯皮格尔和我本人制作，南希·厄普代克和朱莉·斯奈德参与，特约编辑保罗·塔夫、杰克·希特、玛吉·罗克林以及顾问莎拉·沃威尔。制作帮助来自艾米·高原、托德·巴赫曼和西尔维娅·莱穆斯。
[ACKNOWLEDGMENTS]
[致谢]
If you'd like to buy a cassette of this program, call us here at WBEZ in Chicago, 312-832-3380. Or you can listen to most of our programs for free on the internet at our website, www.thislife.org. Thanks to Elizabeth Meister, who runs the site. This American Life is distributed by Public Radio International.
如果你想购买本节目的录音带，请致电芝加哥WBEZ，312-832-3380。或者你可以在我们的网站www.thislife.org免费收听我们的大部分节目。感谢运行该网站的伊丽莎白·迈斯特。《这一美国生活》由国际公共广播电台发行。
[FUNDING CREDITS]
[资金赞助鸣谢]
WBEZ management oversight by Torey Malatia, who is heard at staff meetings managing us this way.
WBEZ管理监督由托里·马拉蒂亚负责，在员工会议上他就是这样管理我们的。
Move the wood! Move the wood.
搬木头！搬木头。
I'm Ira Glass, back next week with more stories of This American Life.
我是艾拉·格拉斯，下周带着更多《这一美国生活》的故事回来。
May God be with thee as they travel.
愿上帝在你旅行时与你同在。
God be with you, friends.
愿上帝与你们同在，朋友们。
PRI, Public Radio International.
PRI，国际公共广播电台。